thank you I'm going to be talking about
ride-sharing schemes and in particular
about the relationship between the city
and the fleet operators which has been
acrimonious at times so far but rather
more than that I've basically been
through the wringer twice on incentives
and scheduling problems and so on once
with the whole internet congestion
control story in an academic setting and
once with incentives for public
transport in a start-up setting so I'm
going to be talking about ambitions and
plans for this question about cities and
fleets and I'll also be talking about
experience of you know things I don't
want to repeat the title of dashboard
istic slightly weird word who's watched
Solaris or had anyone seen the movie
Solaris Solaris as a science fiction
movie starring George Clooney which all
looks very Star Trek aesthetic there's a
much older version by a Soviet director
Tarkovsky which makes space look like a
grimy warehouse with concrete floors
there's also a novel by a polish writer
Stannis waffle M called Solaris what it
came from and and his novel is actually
a not so much science fiction as a
comment on academic journals and
conferences and so on and that the
discipline of Solaris --tx is what he's
into says where I got the title from
okay I'm going to start with something
ancient what drop equity where embrace
paradox I want to refers them later on
so it doesn't hurt to just repeat them
once
what drop was looking at this question
drivers choosing which route to take and
the city whose job it is to provide
infrastructure and the neat thing that
Bray's spotted was the paradoxical
outcome that if you have drivers who
choose which route to take and they want
travel time then sometimes it can lead
to perverse outcomes which do not
maximize total utility so everyone knows
Bray's famous example we have a nice
functioning road network where the
drivers are choosing to allocate
themselves to balance delay the city
happily provides some more
infrastructure the drivers keep on doing
the obvious selfish thing and it leads
to worse outcomes for everyone so morale
is in a distributed system you should
simply not expect good outcomes unless
you build in the right incentives all
right I want to look at users and cities
but with another entity in the middle
the rideshare fleet operator so as
before users choose what route they want
to take but now the natural question is
should I take public transport or should
I take a fleet operator I mean there are
all sorts of other questions you should
I walk should I should I not take this
trip should I travel at different time
and so on but but let's just keep things
reasonably simple public transport or
shed ride-sharing vehicle city I'm going
to continue imagining an altruistic city
who wants to maximize the total utility
among all the users and I'm going to
imagine that it's the city who's taken
this decision providing public transport
and setting the prices of public
transport and in between we have a
rideshare fleet operator whose wiggle
room is it chooses a pricing model the
thing it needs to worry about we're just
hearing about the rebalancing costs and
the ride share operator wants to profit
and so I guess the message from brace
paradox is that when you have different
parties in a in a game then things can
go wrong so it stands to reason if we
have more parties in the game more
things can go wrong
just just to widen the problem a bit and
this is just the beginning they ride
share fleets there are delivery fleets
Amazon and so on and it could be that
pretty soon all of the traffic is
operated by a small number of large
fleet operators more generally the city
might have other goals as well as total
utility we might talk about universal
service goals we might talk about
pollution targets and so on
so just to broaden it out a bit users
are a whole bunch of messy uncoordinated
people rideshare fleets in general we're
talking about a few large operators with
direct user contact through the phone
apps that everyone has and real-time
backends and we're talking about a
regulatory power and the question that
I'm really interested in here is what
should the relationship be between the
regulator and these things just some
initial comments I mean it's late in the
afternoon so me let me build up sizing
and I'm just the beginning of this
project anyway how it should broaden how
should cities relate to fleets well
first thing fleets are a great thing
a fleet can internalize this anarchy of
individual users if we have a single
dominant operator then the single
dominant operator knows what's going on
it's simply not going to use the less
efficient routes so brace prodrugs looks
like a good thing this question if it's
a dominant player is that plausible it
is a statement of principles signed by
the dominant players at the moment
shared mobility principles org which
lists several principles that uber and
lyft and Zipcar and lime and all the
others say should be holding in the
future this is a weird verb we support
that autonomous vehicles in dense urban
areas should be operated only in shed
fleets so there's going to be pressure
from these people to to consolidate
choice down to a small number of
operators
obviously if we have really competing
fleet operators than Prez paradox will
rear its head again
here's another way of looking at things
another type of question I'm going to
just push a little bit harder now on
basically try and formulate the Wardrop
equivalent for multimodal routing with
rideshare fleet operators I'm going to
think of this sort of model as before
we'll have users who can choose what
they're doing City who's setting a
public transit fees and that let me just
be a bit more explicit about what the
right share fleet operator is doing
question basically I'm interested in is
we saw Ray's paradox for simple users
and cities is there a raised paradox
which which crops up when you have fleet
operators so this is my model for fleet
operator it's a very simple model I'm
not worried about it it's all about how
it is that fleet operators incentivize
their drivers I'm going to imagine that
the whole fleet you know uber and all
this fits drivers it's going to
internalize all that and I'm just going
to think of this as single entity and
I'm going to imagine that the only
wiggle room it's allowing us itself is
is that the way we're used to from uber
and so on you you that they set surge
multipliers they imagine that there's a
base fare for each ride based on
distance and based on need based on
demand mismatch they taste a certain
multiply for each ride
so there's a little snippet rail links
substitutable with some road links
demand in various directions around the
network is just for the sake of I need
to put in some mats is a beginning of a
wardrobe equilibrium problem that I'm
proposing for this I'll imagine that
there's intrinsic cost this is the sort
of distance based cost of a road trip
that's what you that's what it costs to
provide the service I'm going to imagine
that this that that's just a fact of
nature the rail fares F IJ between I and
J are set by the city I'll imagine that
the rideshare fleet operator is setting
a surge multiplied mu I based on the
start location I so therefore the cost
that a passenger pays for a ride from i
to j is surge multiplier times base cost
users have a choice of what to do so if
the surge multiplier is high though more
of them will take the public transit
option so emerging out of the surge
multipliers there's an actual load
that's the the demand for rideshare
trips the higher the surge multiplier is
the lower the-- the load alpha will be
i've imagining I'm treating C and F as
constants in this so see the the
distance base cost after transit best
cost so I'm just treating there's this
fixed and I'm looking at this problem
now this is where I'm going to sort of
be being doing looking at the wardrobe
stuff so I'm using Greek letters there
alpha IJ they realized demand as a
function of the surge multipliers so the
fleet sets the surge multipliers this
leads to in imbalance you know there may
be lots of people going this way needs
to get its cars here somehow so the
fleet also has to rebalance its cost its
vehicles so let's say let beta IJ be the
flow rate of empty vehicles going from I
to J and we need a circulation condition
at every node the total lower vehicles
into that node equals total flow going
out
and simple modular rideshare fleet
operator is trying to make sure that the
total revenue it receives this demand
times surge multiplier time-space fare
is equal to the total cost of providing
the service so I'm not not trying to
model any game theoretic tricky stuff
about what these fleet operators do I
just want to understand how these these
might be interacting in a very basic
wardrobe equilibrium stairway so just to
elaborate on an example of what might be
happening let's say we have a rail link
bi-directional rail link from A to B and
the city decides to reduce the fare from
A to B so what does that do that means
that more people will want to take the
rail link because it's cheaper
so some of the a B passengers will shift
from taking the rideshare to taking the
rail so now the rideshare system has has
a deficit of cars at B so it has to make
up that deficit somehow what will it do
well one thing it might do it all
depends on the cost it might send some
vehicles empty vehicles down this
diagonal side where there's no demand
so it's incurring the cost of shipping
empty vehicles around just so that it
can get its curls to be there used to be
productive trips with passengers in now
they're unproductive so it's now it's
got an excess of trips at sea because
there's an excess of trips I'm it's not
going to just sum them idly to B it
might as well reduce the surge
multiplier at sea so it might as well
reduce the surge multiplies so that
passengers and end up taking these
things and that will have a knock-on
effect on the rail to things here it
might lead to well because the the
rideshare will be cheaper than fewer
passengers will take the rail so so just
to take the short cut it might be that
the city reduces the rail fare from A to
B this has knock-on effect of reducing
the rail transit from C to B and
depending on exactly how things are
balancing it could lead to a net
decrease in rail trips I believe I've
done someplace in numerical
investigation I think it's right there
there's some delicacy about the
optimization and I'll just mention
quickly and this arose last week after
discussion with CID I'm going to call it
SIDS paradox from from he thinks it's
not a paradox he thinks that braised
paradox is not a paradox
he thinks it's completely daft to think
that if you don't design engines look
braised you don't breath says if you
don't design in appropriate loss
functions then you end up with the silly
outcome that's not a paradox that's
common sense according to Sid so he
doesn't like the word paradox for this
but I I think it's good right yes
like it seems a bit surprising that we
would get since paradox because reduced
enough load balancer so it seems like
every every vehicle that you sent from
HST that you previously won't have good
balance from A to Z now we do this by
one the number of trips from C to B but
every people that you rebalancing from A
to C is exactly a vehicle that doesn't
get used for right from A to B since
these like it would remain just constant
I think that depends on the relative
costs of the base distances there's the
C IJ between these two versus the C IJ
between those two versus the C IJ here
they can all be different so even though
the number of vehicles there's still the
circulation of vehicles I don't see why
the linear multipliers should lead to
the total revenues being precisely
matched well yes there'll be a number of
trips but even the fares here are
different you know the fare for this
rail link and the fare for that rail
link will be different so so I would
expect there to be equality at the level
of some linear combination of something
based on costs I wouldn't expect there
to be equality based on pure numbers
it said said and there's no reason to
expect it should be optimum when we just
haven't set up anything to be optimum so
it's this idea fleets have the effect of
coupling the actions our city takes in
one part of it system to what might
happen in other parts of the system with
potentially counterintuitive effects
it's a third thought we had to talk I
think it was last week based on the idea
of a victory bottleneck basic idea of
victory bottleneck is it's tough to have
things sitting in city streets treating
the city streets as a parking lot it
shouldn't be a parking lot what would be
ideal is if you could gate stuff keep
the stuff at the edge of the city
keep the middle of the city very
uncongested so that when a car gets in
it's going to get all the way through I
mean it's a very short scale that's what
we heard from Praveen talking about the
Green Wave it's a large scale can we
avoid this can we ensure that that cars
park at the edge and zoom through the
city well his his er just a wish list
inspired by work on internet congestion
control I proposed something like this
as I do which might might just work
the city simulates a virtual road
network it in its simulator it sets the
capacity of each road to be or each
intersection to be 95 percent of what's
actually available and it simulates that
with the current with the actual traffic
we see so the city's got this simulator
it's building up simulated congestion
and it's got an agreement between the
city and the fleet operators telling the
fleet operators that you must assign
routes to your vehicles and you must set
prices based not on real congestion but
on virtual congestion so in other words
the fleets will end up responding to
virtual congestion signals and virtual
congestion ramps up just before real
congestion does and this means that you
won't get actual real congestion but you
will have the correct signals
what really matters here I think to make
it work is you need the right right
communication protocols you need a way
that the the the city can verify that
the fleet's are indeed doing what they
say they are doing and in return you
might imagine something like this the
fleets are given special access to to
narrow parts of the city I mean it
shouldn't make make sense I think it
makes sense there are certain bits of a
city where you really do not want
congestion building up but at the same
time it's nice to have deliveries there
you need some sort of arrangement to
ensure that they remain stable
this idea this came from the story of
internet congestion control and I want
to talk a bit about the the story of
internet congestion control there are
some some lessons from all that process
which I don't think it's a good idea to
repeat and there'll be many of you who
know bits of the story but I'm pretty
sure that most of you don't know all of
this story there are certain bits of it
which I I think so this is the true and
full story of internet congestion
control theory
just a quick prelude some of you have
heard this many many times before in
1986 van Jacobson who's working at
Berkeley notice that throughput on the
internet from here to here this is just
in the hills way and we must be around
here he noticed that throughput dropped
by a factor of a thousand he set out to
figure out what was going on he realized
it was a basic defect in the Internet's
congestion control mechanism and after
some clever thinking and debugging
figured out what it was he devised the
TCP congestion control algorithm which
is this leads to this is a graph of what
a typical computer on the internet sends
there's time on the x-axis transmission
rate on the y-axis Jacobson algorithm
sends more and more traffic until it
detects a congestion in the core backs
away gradually ramps up banks is that
sawtooth I guess that's what Jacobson
did 1986 congestion collapses observed
1988 Jacobson fixed it
1998 Frank Kelly in Cambridge came up
with a mathematical model for internet
congestion control 2002 the fundamental
control theoretic problems behind it
were solved by Glanville income from the
engineering department there were many
many other people our session chair for
example who contributed parts of the
story I'm only picking out certain very
limited piece of the story 2011 the
maths from that after a lot of work
became standardized as TCP friendly
multipath TCP largely driven by Mark
Hanley at UCL and in 2013 Apple Siri
started using multipath TCP ok so it's a
optimistic outline of what happened I'll
tell you what really happened in a
moment but just just a little bit of
math psyche here's the Frank Kelly's
mathematical model the Internet is a
collection of pipes there are flows
which go through various of the pipes
and let's say for user or root R I'll
let
sabe the amount of traffic the traffic
rate on that route he can propose the
optimization problem as follows maximize
the social utility the sum of utility
for user R of the flow that user is
getting overall flow rates such that the
total amount of traffic on a given link
is less than the capacity of that thing
and in the way that we've heard many
times now for example in the the power
control talks and so on
that's an optimization problem you can
turn it into a dynamical system and
algorithm for a slightly relaxed version
of the optimization problem you end up
with something like this so we've got a
differential equation describing how
each user should react and this
corresponds to a very particular choice
of utility function corresponding to
what Jacobson implemented and we have
dual variables which correspond to this
constraint which are communicated from
the core of the network back to each
user
this is um this is the sort of thing
that that I saw Frank Kelly working at
when he was developing these models
hundred going to pushed up now because
it's something which I want to refer to
later on how do you get to grips with
something like this when you're just
starting out you don't know anything at
all about is this the right shape and
model well he just bummed it into Excel
you can write a really simple
differential equation solver in Excel
I've a column for T at the time I have a
column for the current X I shall define
a column for P the packet drop rate at
time T this formula here is just this
formula and then I'll define DX by DT
this is this formula here and update
your x plus delta t times DX by DT so I
looked at this and I thought well that's
crazy everyone knows there are far more
advanced techniques for solving
differential equations and it's crazy
sex so when there are much much better
techniques I didn't say anything cuz you
don't say anything to your supervisor
when you think is doing something daft
[Music]
and then you learn your lesson much
later on as as I'll get to in a bit okay
so once it's all working happily well I
wrote down the differential equations
correspond to single bus TCP you can
have multipath TCP where each flow
adjust its traffic simul tenuously over
several links what ends up happening
here I've got three flows green orange
and purple and I'm slowly changing the
capacity of the links and if you look at
the numbers here no matter what
configuration of capacities I have each
of the three flows is getting precisely
the same bandwidth that they're adapting
the rate carefully that is called
resource pooling it's when a
heterogeneous collection of resources in
the middle of the network gives the
illusion of acting like a single
coordinated resource that everyone's
sharing fairly
resource building and well it's sort of
the flipside of price of anarchy some
people prefer to think of it in one way
so I think this is the way that people
from a scheduling queueing Theory
background prefer to think of it is
resource pooling good well intuitively
is great when when you're not having
little bits of the network which are
underutilized because of bad choices on
the other hand we heard in the previous
workshop this is basically why it is
that when everyone's using ways if
there's gridlock somewhere there's
gridlock absolutely everywhere else
that's also what resource pooling means
that congestion everywhere will rise and
so you end up with the city which is
okay then suddenly the city has
gridlocked system-wide
it works in practice this is an
implementation there's an awful lot of I
thought rather dull work trying to get
it to work happily with all the bits and
pieces on the Internet all this stuff
you need to do to make it implemented in
a Linux kernel and so on here I've got a
graph there's time on the x-axis
positive y-axis is Wi-Fi throughput
negative y-axis is 3G throughput and
when you're sitting in your office
you're mostly using Wi-Fi when you go to
the staircase Wi-Fi cut cell switchover
seamless lead to 3G so that means you
know if you have your phone does this
near a middle of the Skype call and you
lose Wi-Fi connectivity yeah nothing
happens it just switches over seamlessly
rebalances using that very cunning
multipath congestion control the device
by Frank Kelly an Apple implemented it
for Siri user feedback time to first at
20% faster five times reduction of
network failures but then
this is a bit that hurt Apple discarded
the multipath congestion controller and
they just use the brain-dead strategy
send the packet on both my interfaces so
you know I had spent quite quite a long
time working on multipath congestion
control then trying to fine-tune it to
make it acceptable to all of the
internet and Riaan community that was
completely uninteresting it's the
signaling protocol which was the lesson
that the engineers wanted to take from
all of this the control theory model the
control theory results all of that no
use
so all models are wrong some are useful
famous saying by the statistician George
box
what makes models useful I think braids
paradox is a really useful model the
reason that braised paradox is so
compelling is because it goes directly
to what doctors are used to the
Hippocratic oath first do no harm
everyone knows that their models are
wrong so if I have a model which says
I'm going to improve capacity by 50% and
you get 40% well that's that's not
surprising if however I do what the city
thinks it should do and build more
capacity and things get worse than I
have done harm so Braves paradox is a
model which really makes you stop and
think it's much more compelling to have
a reversal non monetarist II as breast
paradox provides than it is to have sort
of epsilon Zahn price of Anarchy and so
on ya think that models are useful for
is when they clarify what the dual
variables are in your model that's what
everyone took away from a multipass TCP
in the end it gave her a great deal of
clear thinking about the dual variables
the signals which need to be composed
from the network to the end systems that
was far far far more important than
anything to do with utility functions
but the other lesson that does not
really come out in the TCP story but
came out in all the work that I was
involved in incentives is that no one
will ever bother implementing your
system unless they can see how it's
useful to them and the really key word
there is see how do they see how it will
be useful to them I spent six years
working on incentives for for public
transport and so here are some stories
about what we need to do to make users
see that things are useful to them if
these four pictures one is dystopian
yeah we know which one is dystopian one
is science fiction
which one if the does anyone recognize
this Westworld you're up on your HBO
okay one of these two is science fiction
any guesses which one
a little-known fact Minority Report the
amazing UI that Tom Cruise was using
Minority Report was developed by a
company called would let me get this
name oblong and they have a product
called mezzanine info presents suite so
you can book rooms in in London Los
Angeles and similar you have giant
minority cell dashboards which you can
use you you go there you higher ease it
for your conference calls and so on so
this is oblong inspired this I mean they
that they were consultants on when I
receive report and now they have a fully
fair project you can just go ahead and
use it this is the only science-fiction
one what matters users have to be able
to see that what you're proposing will
be beneficial to them they need a data
dashboard and the data dashboard has to
where it has to be based on
visualization fundamentally that's the
only way they can see anything has to be
a platform for exploring testing new
scenarios investigating hypotheses
before I say that I'll say I really
enjoyed David's talk because it was you
know it was all about proper use of data
wonderful demonstration of how he should
be using data the only trouble with
David's talk was that it should not take
a Cornell professor and PhD student to
do those sorts of things it should be
something where we're you know with the
huge amounts of data if the world is
going to benefit from the big data it
has to be that people who have extra
level skills can do the sort of thing
that we heard about and there's just
nothing at the moment that they can use
which would enable them to do those
sorts of of data explorations so this is
this is actually what's needed there
needs to be a way for the sort of
control theory game theory optimization
queueing Theory scheduling all that sort
of stuff to be productized and turned
into something sort of excel like that
can be exported to the wider world
otherwise it remains far too narrow a a
discipline where do these things come
from design for data dashboards and they
there are people who do this at the
moment they're the infovis community the
HCI community human-computer interaction
programming language community they have
not really gotten done properly into
what data dashboards need to do because
I think they're too much oriented around
programming basically when you work with
data it is programming of a sort but but
the visualizations the interactions you
need to be able to do those should be
inspired by what the optimization
problems are telling you you look at
optimization problems like that we had
the Wardrobe equilibrium and so on you
figure out what are the key quantities
that I need to be capturing what are the
dual variables those things need to be
embedded in what you can do with your
data dashboard so you need to think what
the operations that my optimization
problem that my control theoretic
formulation requires me to be able to
show and then how can I have a generic
excel like product which will let an
arbitrary user come along and implement
those things
been through various steps
I went actually it's 4:30 now so run I
won't go through the various attempts
but basically over the past six years I
had various attempts at at ways to think
about this trying to break down the idea
of what is a simulation what is a data
set what is a trace how can you turn
those into reusable components but what
I will say is that we're hiring so if
any of you have are looking for a
postdoc or any of you have a postdoc who
is looking for something to do for the
next two years and they want to come to
London where the accommodation is
cheaper than San Francisco and the food
is better so look at these two things at
the alan turing institute hosts in the
british library as a project with three
faculty one PhD one software engineer
trying to explore just these questions
there'll be one topic which is exploring
this business of user fleet city
interaction and what data do the cities
need to have in order to understand it
with a view towards shaping how it is
that cities and fleets will interact you
know how will cities be regulating what
these can do the other part will be
singling controlled like like Previn was
talking about but the particular
emphasis is firstly using reinforcement
learning to think about signal control
in the network secondly and much more
importantly asking how do we
productionize the use of machine
learning so that machine learning is a
drop-in module so that is typical you
know someone in a local authority can
say retain my algorithm on this new data
because I think it's been affected by
what happened last week retrain it test
it see if that's an improvement and
rerun it
so reinforcement learning with an
emphasis on how do you integrate machine
learning and data dashboards so if
anyone knows any postdocs who want to do
this for two years or one year it's up
to them let me know thank you
[Applause]
so can you can you expand a little bit
when you say the the decibel should
really be the core of it is the data
signals and operations which I think
tend to agree very much how do you make
that concrete we have a DB charging in
the structure content so we are getting
data and we're facing exactly the
problem that yourself how can we extract
it and present it in a way that can be
useful it's not it's not true it's not
trivial at all I'd say there are
basically three tool sets that people
have their edite computer background
people who talk SQL there are the data
Sanctus background people whose are or
Python who talk data frames and
occasionally spark and then there are
the visualization people who use ggplot
or tableau or matplotlib if they're
unlucky and and the trouble is that
these are three separate universes and
there should not be three separate
universes I think that there's a way to
tie together graphical interaction and
query modification so that you reach out
and touch something on your graphic and
that corresponds directly to modifying
an aspect of the query statement so it's
just a small algebraic step I think
there is a going to be unification of
these two and once you have that once
there becomes a canonical way that a
query can automatically be translated
into a graphic and that the graphic can
be modified then I think that that will
take us most of the way there always be
a place for the the you know high
priesthood of data scientists who need
spark who need all the richness but
there's an awful lot you know Excel
level stuff which can be done with much
less I said that that that's my research
agenda now
thank you
[Applause]